Dok asks in episode 62 you asked if we  were going to submit a question via  Instagram I said no because I don't have  a smartphone so I can't get an account  so I borrowed my daughter's phone  to open an account and upload the stupid  question my question is are you happy  now Gary doc you and I have been jamming  and interacting on Twitter for a very  long time and the fact that you care  enough about me and this show to jump  into new waters is in essence the entire  thesis of what I do for a living would  just try to get people to stop drawing  lines in the sand and not be religious  and jump in and do new things and taste  them and then decide if they're stupid I  am  happy but I'm gonna be a hell of a lot  happier in nine and a half months when I  go back to your account that you just  put up and see enormous ly beautiful  selfie shots from the dock